- So has he made you
change any diapers yet?
(lighthearted music)
- We are so excited to be
able to recommend Jackson
for this reading program,
so if you just wanna go home
and talk it over with your
husband and let us know.
- I mean, I can let you know now.
I think it would be a great idea.
- Uh, I mean, it's okay.
You can go home, talk it over.
- So you're a stay-at-home mom now?
- Yeah.
- And you're totally okay with
your husband being the one
who brings home the bacon?
- Aw, look at you
pitching in doing laundry.
So helpful.
- Oh, sorry, there's no changing table
in the women's restroom.
- There isn't?
- No, you can try across
the street, though.
- Hi.
- [Woman] Hi, we're here.
- [Man] She looks great.
- [Woman] Oh, thank you.
- Did Dad get her dressed?
(children laughing)
- [Dark-Haired Girl] No,
don't throw it by me!
(ball thuds)
- I bet you can't wait
to get back to work.
- Uh-oh, looks like someone
got stuck babysitting this weekend.
- Well, I'm not getting paid,
so I think it's just parenting.
- [Woman in Stripes]
(growls) I'm a dinosaur.
(children shriek)
(woman yells)
(children laugh)
- Don't let your girlfriends
see you acting like this.
- Hi.
- There a reason you're
at the playground today?
- Yeah, I'm here with my kid.
- Yeah, which one?
- The one right over there
in the No Fear shirt.
- What's his name?
- Jackson.
- Hey, Jackson, is this your mom?
- [Woman] Are you okay?
Did you get an owie?
Let me see.
- [Man] Aw, sweetie.
- [Woman] Can I give it a kiss?
- I'll go get your husband, okay.
I'll get him up here in just a sec.
They always want their daddy.
- Nah. (laughs)
(lighthearted music)